Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The city of Nantes is situated in the northwest of France, in the heart of the Loire Valley wine region. The Loire River curves through the city, which is defined by its striking blend of heritage architecture, 18th century facades, and Mediterranean-inspired dwellings. The layout is typical of many French cities, a medieval town centre framed by densely packed
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。南特市位于法国西北部，地处卢瓦尔河谷葡萄酒产区的核心地带。卢瓦尔河蜿蜒穿过这座城市，其特点是融合了醒目的传统建筑、18世纪的建筑立面以及地中海风格的住宅。这种布局是许多法国城市的典型特征，一个由密集排列的
historic suburban buildings before giving way to newer homes and public housing. before giving way to newer homes and public housing. As the sixth largest city in France, Nantes has been praised by the European Commission for offering a higher quality of life. The six-member Dupont de Léganès family lived at 55 Robert Schuman Boulevard, a narrow two-storey residence in a wealthy residential area west of the city. Their home was part of a row of matching terraced buildings overlooking a busy thoroughfare, interspersed with patisseries, bars, and other businesses. The family lived a comfortable, middle-class life. Fifty-year-old patriarch Xavier Dupont de Léganès had aristocratic ties and noble ancestry. He was raised in a devout Catholic household in the regal, upper-class city of Versailles,
历史悠久郊区建筑环绕的中世纪市中心，随后让位于更新的住宅和公共住房。在让位于更新的住宅和公共住房之前。作为法国第六大城市，南特因提供更高质量的生活而受到欧盟委员会的称赞。杜邦·德·利戈内斯（Dupont de Ligonès）一家六口住在罗伯特·舒曼大道55号，这是一栋位于该市西部富裕住宅区狭窄的两层住宅。他们的家是一排俯视着繁忙大道的联排建筑的一部分，其间穿插着法式面包店、酒吧和其他企业。这家人过着舒适的中产阶级生活。50岁的家族家长泽维尔·杜邦·德·利戈内斯（Xavier Dupont de Ligonès）拥有贵族关系和高贵的血统。他在凡尔赛这座富丽堂皇的上流社会城市的一个虔诚的天主教家庭中长大，
west of Paris. It was there that he met Agnès Sordanger, an elegant young woman two years his junior. Xavier and Agnès dated throughout their teens and became engaged, but the relationship ended before their marriage went ahead. In the years following their breakup, Xavier indulged his love of American culture and country music by travelling the famous highway Route 66 in the United States. The couple reunited in Versailles, at which point Agnes had a one-year-old child named Arthur from a previous relationship. Xavier told a friend he was in love and willing to take on the responsibility of parenting Arthur, which was unusual for a man of his status at the time. Xavier and Agnes were married in a quiet ceremony in 1991 and went on to have three children, Thomas, Anne and Benoit. The family lived throughout France
位于巴黎以西部。正是在那里，他遇到了比他小两岁的优雅年轻女子阿涅斯·索尔当热（Agnès Sordanger）。泽维尔和阿涅斯在整个青少年时期都在约会并订婚了，但这段关系在他们结婚前就结束了。在她分手后的几年里，泽维尔通过在美国旅行著名的6号公路，纵情于他对美国文化和乡村音乐的热爱。这对夫妇在凡尔赛重聚，当时阿涅斯与前一段关系育有一个一岁名为阿瑟（Arthur）的孩子。泽维尔告诉一位朋友，他恋爱了，并愿意承担抚养阿瑟的责任，这在当时他这种身份的男人中是不寻常的。泽维尔和阿涅斯于1991年在一次安静的仪式上结婚，随后育有三个孩子：托马斯（Thomas）、安妮（Anne）和伯努瓦（Benoit）。这家人在法国各地生活过
and spent nine months travelling across the United States before settling in Nantes in 2003. before settling in Nantes in 2003. Xavier was an entrepreneur who owned several small online businesses, including one based in Miami. His main focus was a hotel and restaurant guide for truckers, travelling salespeople and business owners titled Route de Commerce U, or Salesperson's Road in English. Agnes worked part-time as a supervisor at a primary school and also taught religious studies at a local Catholic school. By 2011, the couple's eldest child, 20-year-old Arthur, was studying information technology at a university an hour away. He boarded on campus but returned to the family home in Nantes every weekend, where he worked at a local pizzeria. His brother,
并在美国各地旅行了九个月，然后于2003年在南特安定下来。在2003年安定下来之前。泽维尔是一位企业家，拥有几家小型在线企业，其中包括一家总部设在迈阿密的在线企业。他的主要重点是为卡车司机、旅行推销员和企业主提供酒店和餐厅指南，名为“商业路线U”（Route de Commerce U），英文为“推销员之路”（Salesperson's Road）。阿涅斯在小学兼职担任主管，还在当地一所天主教学校教授宗教研究。到2011年，这对夫妇的大孩子、20岁的阿瑟正在一小时车程外的一所大学学习信息技术。他住在校园里，但每个周末都会回到南特的老家，并在当地的一家比萨店工作。他的兄弟，
18-year-old Thomas, had moved an hour east to the city of Angers where he studied music, though he too visited home most weekends. The family's youngest, 16-year-old Anne and 13-year-old Benoit, still lived with their parents, attending school at the esteemed Pèverie Sacred Heart Catholic College. Anne was a dedicated and popular student who played the piano, did some occasional modelling work, and was passionate about her religion. did some occasional modelling work and was passionate about her religion. Benoit was equally popular. He enjoyed rollerblading and singing in the church choir and was looking forward to his upcoming confirmation sacrament. On the night of Sunday April 3 2011, the Dupont de Léganès family, minus Thomas, went out for dinner and a movie.
18岁的托马斯搬到了东边一小时车程的昂热市学习音乐，尽管他也是大多数周末都回家。家里最小的孩子，16岁的安妮和13岁的伯努瓦，仍然和父母住在一起，在受人尊敬的佩维里圣心天主教书院（Pèverie Sacred Heart Catholic College）上学。安妮是一个尽职尽责且受欢迎的学生，弹钢琴，偶尔做模特工作，并且对她的宗教充满热情。偶尔做模特工作并且对她的宗教充满热情。伯努瓦同样受欢迎。他喜欢轮滑和在教堂唱诗班唱歌，并且期待着即将到来的坚振圣事。2011年4月3日星期日晚上，除托马斯外的杜邦·德·利戈内斯一家出去吃晚饭和看电影。
Upon their return home, Xavier phoned his sister, Christine, and left a voice message relaying the pleasant events of their evening. He ended the message by saying, Okay, I'm going to put the kids to bed and say goodnight to everyone. Talk to you soon. Maybe. Over the following week, neighbours of 55 Robert Schuman Boulevard noticed the property had fallen unusually silent and still. Its window shutters, which were usually kept open, had been closed for some time. The black Volkswagen Golf convertible belonging to Agnes Dupont de Léganès had been parked on a nearby street for several days. The family's two pet Labradors were heard howling and crying throughout the night a week prior, but hadn't made a sound since. On Wednesday April 13, a concerned neighbour called the Nant Police and four officers arrived at the DuPont de Ligonais residence to conduct a welfare
回到家后，泽维尔给他的姐姐克里斯蒂娜（Christine）打电话，留下一条语音留言，讲述他们当晚愉快的事情。他在留言结束时说：“好了，我要去哄孩子们睡觉，跟大家说晚安。回头聊。也许吧。”在接下来的一周里，罗伯特·舒曼大道55号的邻居们注意到这处房产变得异常安静和平静。它的窗户百叶窗通常是开着的，但已经关了一段时间。属于阿涅斯·杜邦·德·利戈内斯的黑色大众高尔夫敞篷车已经停在附近的一条街上好几天了。前一周整晚都能听到家里两只宠物拉布拉多犬的嚎叫和哭泣，但自那以后就没有发出过声音。4月13日星期三，一位担忧的邻居打电话给南特警察，四名警官抵达杜邦·德·利戈内斯住宅进行福利
check. A printed sign was pinned to the letterbox that read, A printed sign was pinned to the letterbox that read, Please return all mail to sender. Thank you. The officers found the family home in a relatively orderly condition, with the kitchen and bathroom spotlessly clean. The fridge and bedroom wardrobes had been emptied and the beds had been stripped of their sheets. Photos had been removed from their picture frames and various cupboards and drawers were close to empty, but they found no evidence of foul play. Police were contacted again later that afternoon,
检查。信箱上贴着一张打印的标语，上面写着：信箱上贴着一张打印的标语，上面写着：请将所有信件退回发件人。谢谢。警官们发现这栋家庭住宅处于相对有序的状态，厨房和浴室一尘不染。冰箱和卧室衣橱里的东西都被腾空了，床上的床单也被拆掉了。照片已经从相框中取出，各种橱柜和抽屉几乎是空的，但他们没有发现任何犯罪证据。那天下午晚些时候，警察再次被联系，
this time by a member of Agnes' family, who had in their possession a four-page typed letter authored by Xavier. Several other relatives and friends of the Dupont de Léganès family had been mailed the same letter. It read, in part, Hi everyone. Huge surprise. We have to leave urgently for the US due to a very particular set of circumstances that we will explain below. You're receiving this letter by conventional post because for the next few years, we can't communicate any other way for safety reasons. When you read this letter, we will no longer be in France and won't be able to return for an as-yet undetermined period of time.
这次是阿涅斯的一位家属，他手里拿着一封由泽维尔撰写的四页打印信。杜邦·德·利戈内斯家人的几个其他亲戚和朋友也收到了同样的信。信中部分写道：“大家好。巨大的惊喜。由于我们将在下面解释的一系列非常特殊的情况，我们必须紧急前往美国。你们收到这封信是通过传统邮政，因为在接下来的几年里，出于安全原因，我们不能以任何其他方式交流。当你读到这封信时，我们将不再在法国，并且在一段尚未确定的时间内无法返回。
You must be wondering what's going on. Here's the story, at least as much as we're allowed to tell you. When we started our company in Miami in 2003, the person who helped us start put us in contact with the DEA, Drug Enforcement Administration, a sort of American drug squad with agents on the ground in several countries, who were looking for a French national to infiltrate the French nightclub scene to obtain information about drug trafficking and money laundering networks without drawing attention to themselves. Through my business, Route de Commerce U, I found myself in a different city every evening with a legitimate reason to make contact with nightclub bosses,
你们一定想知道发生了什么事。这就是故事，至少是我们被允许告诉你的那么多。当我们于2003年在迈阿密创立公司时，帮助我们创业的人使我们与DEA（美国缉毒局）取得了联系，这是一种美式缉毒队，在几个国家有地面特工，他们正在寻找一名法国国民渗透到法国夜总会场景中，以获取有关贩毒和洗钱网络的信息，而不引起对自己的注意。通过我的企业“商业路线U”，我每天晚上都在不同的城市，有充分的理由与夜总会老板建立联系，
so I was the ideal candidate. Once I was tested and briefed, I accepted my mission of working incognito for the DEA under the condition that I maintain secrecy. Everything has gone according to plan in the nightclubs for the last seven years, until now. With the information that I have collected in this time, I have become a key witness in an upcoming trial involving major international drug trafficking kingpins. The trial will have to take place in the US in the next few years. The date has not yet been determined. What complicates matters is that certain tips had recently led us to believe that my cover may have been blown, and unfortunately, we received confirmation of this yesterday.
所以我成为了理想的候选人。一旦我接受了测试和简报，我就接受了在保密条件下为DEA隐姓埋名工作的任务。过去七年里，夜总会的一切都按计划进行，直到现在。凭借我在此期间收集的信息，我已成为即将审判的主要国际贩毒巨头的关键证人。审判将在未来几年内在美进行。具体日期尚未确定。使事情变得复杂的是，某些线索最近让我们相信我的身份可能已经曝光，不幸的是，我们昨天收到了这一确认。
and unfortunately, we received confirmation of this yesterday. Therefore, the situation has now become potentially dangerous for us here and has required us to take emergency measures. When I first went undercover, I accepted that I might be placed into the Federal Witness Protection Program. This is what we now have to do, and we're not doing it with any excitement, but because it's necessary and there's no way around it. So we have been taken into the protective custody of the US government and transferred to the US, and we have new identities, which must, of course, be kept secret. By the time you read this letter, we will officially no longer exist as French citizens. We will be US citizens, living in the US like any other US citizen. Except, we will be forbidden
不幸的是，我们昨天收到了这一确认。因此，这里的情况现在对我们来说变得具有潜在危险，并要求我们采取紧急措施。当我第一次卧底时，我接受了我可能会被安置在联邦证人保护计划中的事实。这就是我们现在必须做的，我们这样做并不是因为兴奋，而是因为这是必要的，而且别无选择。因此，我们已被美国政府的保护性拘留并转移到美国，我们有了新的身份，当然，必须对此保密。当你读完这封信时，我们将正式不再作为法国公民存在。我们将是美国公民，像任何其他美国公民一样生活在美国。除了，我们将被禁止
from communicating with our family and friends for an undetermined period of time, at least until the trial is over. The hardest thing? There is some tension with the children, who couldn't tell their friends and are forbidden from using Facebook and other online networks. We had to give up the dogs. Luckily, someone took both of them so they won't be separated. The children's schools are aware, as are Arthur's and Thomas' landlords and Agnes' and Arthur's employers. The official story is that we have been transferred to Australia for work without providing any specific details. It would be good if you could spread this false story on Facebook and elsewhere. We hope it doesn't drag on for too many years.
在一段不确定的时间内与我们的家人和朋友交流，至少直到审判结束。最难的是什么？孩子们有些紧张，他们不能告诉他们的朋友，并被禁止使用Facebook和其他在线网络。我们不得不放弃这些狗。幸运的是，有人把这两只狗都带走了，这样它们就不会被分开了。孩子们的学校都知道，阿瑟和托马斯的房东以及阿涅斯和阿瑟的雇主也都知道。官方的说法是，我们为了工作被调到了澳大利亚，没有提供任何具体的细节。如果你能在Facebook和其他地方传播这个虚假的故事，那就太好了。我们希望这不会拖延太多年。
elsewhere. We hope it doesn't drag on for too many years. Of course, we send all our love and a thinking of you very much during this enforced separation. Take good care of yourselves. We'll have so many stories to tell you later on. Xavier, Agnes, Arthur, Thomas, Anne, and Benoit. The hard part is going to be getting used to our new names. The letter went on to explain that the family had been allowed to store valuable personal items, such as photos, souvenirs, computers, paperwork, jewellery and weapons into a safe, but they hadn't had time to finish sorting through the rest of their possessions. They didn't trust the Americans to do a thorough job and assigned the task to friends, with the key to their house available in the meter box outside. 70% of the household items were to be taken to the dump, excluding several items of
在其他地方。我们希望这不会拖延太多年。当然，在这场强制分离期间，我们向你们致以所有的爱，并非常想念你们。好好照顾自己。以后我们有那么多故事要讲。泽维尔、阿涅斯、阿瑟、托马斯、安妮和伯努瓦。困难的部分将是习惯我们的新名字。”信中继续解释说，这家人被允许将有价值的个人物品（如照片、纪念品、电脑、纸质文件、珠宝和武器）存放在保险箱里，但他们没有时间整理其余的财产。他们不信任美国人能彻底完成这项工作，并将这项任务委派给朋友，屋外电表箱里有他们房子的钥匙。70%的家居用品将被运往垃圾场，除了几件
expensive furniture, which were family heirlooms that needed to be shipped to Agnes' family. Some other high-value items should be sold, including the family's two cars, the Volkswagen Golf Convertible and Citroen Zantia, with the proceeds given to Xavier's sister, Christine. A third car, a Citroen C5, was unsellable and had already been scrapped for parts. The property's utility services needed to be cancelled, with relevant paperwork left on the dining room table. The foosball table, entertainment equipment and musical instruments could be divided between those who helped clear out the home. The letter specified,
昂贵的家具，这些是需要运给阿涅斯家人的传家宝。其他一些高价值物品应该出售，包括家里的两辆车，大众高尔夫敞篷车和雪铁龙扎蒂亚（Citroen Zantia），所得款项交给了泽维尔的姐姐克里斯蒂娜。第三辆车，一辆雪铁龙C5（Citroen C5），无法出售，并且已经被拆解成零件。该物业的水电气服务需要取消，相关文件留在餐桌上。桌上足球、娱乐设备和乐器可以在那些帮忙清理家园的人之间分配。信中具体说明，
No need to worry about the metal detector or the canoe which can stay there, nor the rubble and the other mess piled up on the terrace, at the end of the garden and in the basement. That was all there when we moved in. Through his work, Xavier had been developing a loyalty system for restaurant guests and he encouraged a friend to pursue the project, explaining it would provide his family with a comfortable income upon their return to France. He asked his sister Christine and her husband Bertram to manage the family's bank accounts, where payments of approximately 4,000 euros would be coming in for the next few months.
不用担心金属探测器或独木舟，它们可以留在那儿，也不用担心堆在露台、花园尽头和地下室的瓦砾和其他杂物。我们搬进来时就都在那儿了。通过他的工作，泽维尔一直在为餐厅客人开发一个忠诚度系统，他鼓励一位朋友继续这个项目，并解释说这将在他的家人返回法国后为他们提供舒适的收入。他请他的姐姐克里斯蒂娜和她的丈夫伯特兰（Bertram）管理家里的银行账户，在接下来的几个月里，将有大约4000欧元的款项打入。
Christine initially thought the letter was a joke, but recognised the methodical instructions listed within were typical of her brother. She had never quite understood what Xavier did for work and the possibility that he was an undercover agent made sense to her. Bertram was less convinced, questioning the letter's light tone, and thought it strange that Xavier took the time to detail and delegate tasks under such critical circumstances. The American Embassy in Paris contacted the United States Drug Enforcement Administration where officials confirmed they had never heard of Xavier Dupont de Liguenesse and neither he nor his family were part of any witness protection scheme. Police attended the Dupont de Liguenesse residence for a second time
克里斯蒂娜最初以为这封信是个玩笑，但认出了其中列出的有条不紊的指令是她哥哥的典型特征。她从来没有完全理解泽维尔是做什么工作的，他是卧底特工的可能性对她来说是有道理的。伯特兰则不太相信，对信中轻松的语气提出质疑，并认为泽维尔在如此严峻的情况下花时间详细说明和委派任务很奇怪。巴黎的美国大使馆联系了美国缉毒局，官员们证实他们从未听说过泽维尔·德·利戈内斯（Xavier Dupont de Liguenesse），他和他的家人都不是任何证人保护计划的一部分。警察第二次前往杜邦·德·利戈内斯住宅
and walked through the house, garden and cellar, but once again found nothing particularly concerning. It appeared as though the family had simply left in a hurry. The timeline leading up to the family's sudden departure exposed far more red flags. Xavier and Agnes took three of their children, Arthur, Anne and Benoit, out for dinner and to see a movie on Sunday April 3. Their remaining son, Thomas, was not in attendance as he spent that weekend at his college campus in Angers. The morning of Monday April 4, Xavier phoned his wife's employer to inform them that she had fallen ill with gastro and wouldn't be coming in. Agnes' boss later
并穿过了房屋、花园和地窖，但再次没有发现任何特别令人担忧的事情。看起来这家人只是匆忙离开。导致这家人突然离开的时间线暴露了更多的危险信号。泽维尔和阿涅斯带着他们的三个孩子阿瑟、安妮和伯努瓦于4月3日星期日出去吃晚饭和看电影。他们剩下的儿子托马斯没有出席，因为他在昂热的大学校园度过了那个周末。4月4日星期一早上，泽维尔给他妻子的雇主打电话，通知他们她患了胃肠炎，不会来上班了。阿涅斯的上司后来
received a text message from Xavier stating her illness had worsened and she had been hospitalised. When colleagues tried to reach out, a text message from Agnes informed them that she was uncontactable while in hospital. At the same time, Xavier phoned Anne and Benoit's school, excusing their absence over the coming days due to illness. That evening, Xavier drove to Angers to pay Thomas a visit, taking his son out for a meal at a high-end restaurant. The pair were courteous to staff but barely spoke to one another. As they dined, Thomas announced he wasn't feeling well and walked outside to get some fresh air and rest in the car. The next day, Thomas was at a friend's house when
收到泽维尔发来的一条短信，称她的病情恶化并已经住院。当同事们试图联系时，阿涅斯的一条短信通知他们，她在医院期间无法联系。与此同时，泽维尔给安妮和伯努瓦的学校打电话，为他们未来几天因病缺勤请假。那天晚上，泽维尔开车去昂热探望托马斯，带着他的儿子去一家高档餐厅吃饭。两人对员工很有礼貌，但几乎不说话。吃饭时，托马斯宣布他感觉很不舒服，并走到外面呼吸新鲜空气并在车里休息。第二天，托马斯在朋友家时
he received a call from his father alerting him to his mother's hospitalisation following a bicycle accident. Thomas told his friend her injuries weren't serious, but his father had insisted he return home that night. He sent a Facebook message to an ex-girlfriend with whom he was still friends to let her know before boarding a train to Nantes at approximately 10.30pm. He disembarked at the city station a half an hour later, where his father was waiting. Mobile phone data revealed the pair drove to the family home, arriving at approximately 11.45 p.m. The following morning of Wednesday April 6, two of Anne's friends paid her a visit to see how she was doing. The shutters on her bedroom window were closed, though a light shone from inside another upstairs room, suggesting someone
他接到父亲的电话，提醒他母亲因自行车事故住院。托马斯告诉他的朋友，她的伤势并不严重，但他的父亲坚持要他今晚回家。在晚上10点30分左右登上开往南特的火车之前，他给了一位仍是朋友的前女友发了一条Facebook消息告知她。半小时后他在城市车站下车，他的父亲在那里等候。手机数据显示，两人开车回到了家里，大约在晚上11点45分到达。第二天4月6日星期三，安妮的两个朋友来看望她，看她过得怎么样。她卧室窗户的百叶窗关着，不过楼上另一个房间亮着灯，暗示有人
was home. A note stuck to the front door warned visitors not to ring the bell as the children were sick and shouldn't be woken. The girls left and received a text from Anne the next day explaining she was still sick and wouldn't be around for a few days. That same day, Thomas' friend texted to see how he was doing and was sent in response, I'm not coming to yours, I'm ill. A second text arrived later that day and read, Really ill. I'm not coming to class. Their blunt and impersonal tone struck his friend as odd, as Thomas typically wrote long, warm messages peppered with jokes. The same friend received a third and final text from Thomas the next day that read,
在家。前门上贴着一张纸条，警告访客不要按铃，因为孩子们生病了，不应该被吵醒。女孩们离开了，第二天收到安妮的一条短信，解释她还在生病，几天内不会露面。同一天，托马斯的朋克发短信看他过得怎么样，并收到了回复：“我不去你那儿，我生病了。”那天晚些时候收到了第二条短信，上面写着：“真的病了。我不去上课。”他们生硬且不冷不热的语气让他的朋友觉得很奇怪，因为托马斯通常会写长而温暖的夹杂着笑话的信息。同一位朋友第二天收到了托马斯的第三条也是最后一条短信，上面写着：
I'm out of battery, my dad's looking for a new charger for me. Like his younger siblings, Arthur had also been absent from class. His college had been contacted by Xavier at the beginning of the week, who explained that Arthur had been hospitalised following a scooter accident. Arthur's girlfriend went to the DuPont de Liguenès home to check in, but no one answered the door, even though a light was on downstairs. On Thursday April 7, a friend of Arthur's sent a text message to Agnes asking if her son was okay. The response read,
“我手机没电了，我爸爸在给我找新充电器。”就像他的弟弟妹妹一样，阿瑟也一直没有去上课。他的大学在周初被泽维尔联系过，泽维尔解释说阿瑟因滑板车事故住院。阿瑟的女朋友去杜邦·德·利戈内斯家查看，但没有人应门，尽管楼下亮着灯。4月7日星期 Thursday，阿瑟的一个朋友给阿涅斯发了一条短信，询问她的儿子是否还好。回应写道：
Hi, don't worry. Arthur has gone with his dad to the Paris region to help with the move. He forgot his cell and my husband has forgotten his battery charger. We told the school he fell off his scooter. He'll be back on Saturday working at the pizza bar. Have a nice day." Xavier was active over email during this time, sending a message to a long-time friend, Vincent, offering him ownership of his business websites. He needed a speedy response as he was finally fulfilling his dream of moving to the United States with his family and they would be leaving the following day. Vincent could assume ownership of the websites on the condition that he didn't
“嗨，别担心。阿瑟和他的父亲一起去了巴黎地区帮忙搬家。他忘了手机，我丈夫忘了他的电池充电器。我们告诉学校他从滑板车上摔下来了。他星期六会回来在比萨店工作。祝你有个美好的一天。”泽维尔在这期间通过电子邮件很活跃，给一位老朋友文森特（Vincent）发了一条消息，提供给他他的企业网站的所有权。他需要快速回复，因为他终于实现了带着家人搬到美国的梦想，他们第二天就要离开。文森特可以承担网站的所有权，条件是他不
tell anyone about the deal or the DuPont de Ligonasse's upcoming departure. Xavier's email declared, If you are not interested, the sites will disappear from the web. Personally, I do not care. I turn the page and go to new adventures. Vincent wrote back right away agreeing to the deal and Xavier provided him with the relevant information and access codes immediately. Vincent then sent another email asking Xavier for written authorisation to manage the domain names, but didn't receive a reply. The following night, Xavier responded to an email from his brother-in-law, Bertram, that asked how things were going with the family.
告诉任何人这笔交易或杜邦·德·利戈内斯即将离开的消息。泽维尔的电子邮件宣称：“如果你不感兴趣，这些网站将从网络上消失。就个人而言，我不在乎。我翻过那一页，去追求新的冒险。”文森特立刻回信同意这笔交易，泽维尔立即向他提供了相关信息和访问代码。文森特随后发送了另一封电子邮件，要求泽维尔提供书面授权来管理域名，但没有得到回复。第二天晚上，泽维尔回复了姐夫伯特兰的一封电子邮件，询问家里情况如何。
It read, Everything's fine, Bertram. You'll hear more detailed news soon through Christine. Bye for now. All the best, Xavier. Around midday on Saturday April 9, a neighbour saw Xavier out on the street holding a bottle of some kind. By then, the letters about his family's inclusion into the Witness Protection Program were in circulation, with the first received by Xavier's best friend, Emmanuel. by Xavier's best friend, Emmanuel. He re-read the letter multiple times, unsure what to make of it, before heading to 55 Robert Schuman Boulevard, only to find no one home. The house keys weren't in the meter box as the letter described, but in their place was a handwritten post-it note informing they would be deposited between Sunday and Monday night.
上面写着：“一切都很好，伯特兰。你很快就会通过克里斯蒂娜听到更详细的消息。先这样。祝一切都好，泽维尔。”4月9日星期六中午左右，一位邻居看到泽维尔拿着某种瓶子在街上。那时，关于他的家人加入证人保护计划的信件正在流传，第一封由泽维尔最好的朋友埃马纽埃尔（Emmanuel）收到。由泽维尔最好的朋友埃马纽埃尔收到。他把这封信重新读了好几遍，不知道该怎么做，然后前往罗伯特舒曼大道55号，结果发现家里没人。信中所描述的房主钥匙不在电表箱里，但在它们的位置是一张手写的便条，通知它们将在周日至周一晚间之间存放。
That same evening, Xavier arrived to Arthur's College where he was witnessed cleaning out his son's dorm room. The next morning, his metallic blue Citroen C5 was caught speeding by a traffic camera on the way to Angers, where at 9am he began clearing Thomas' room of its belongings. A neighbour held the door open for Xavier, who nonchalantly commented something along the lines of, what you wouldn't do for your children. On Monday April 11, Anne and Benoit School received an envelope that contained a cheque covering the teenagers' fees for the remainder of the academic year. They also received a typed letter from Xavier, advising that he was withdrawing his children
当天晚上，泽维尔来到阿瑟的学院，被目击清理他儿子的宿舍房间。第二天早上，他那辆金属蓝色的雪铁龙C5在去昂热的路上被交通摄像头拍到超速行驶，上午9点他在那里开始清理托马斯房间里的物品。一位邻居为泽维尔开着门，泽维尔漫不经心地评论道：“为了孩子，你什么都做得出来。”4月11日星期一，安妮和伯努瓦的学校收到一个信封，里面有一张支票，涵盖了青少年剩余学年的费用。他们还收到了泽维尔的一封打印信，建议他让孩子们退学
as his work required the family to urgently relocate to Australia. as his work required the family to urgently relocate to Australia. Similar letters also arrived to Agnes' workplace, the pizza shop where Arthur was employed, as well as the colleges he and Thomas attended, all establishing the family's sudden departure overseas. Upon receiving the perplexing letter, Agnes' boss attempted to call her, receiving the perplexing letter, Agnes' boss attempted to call her, but there was no response. Several people tried to contact the family throughout the week, but to no avail, and their Facebook accounts remained inactive. Two relatives visited Robert Schumann Boulevard to investigate, finding the house key to number 55 had since been put in the meter box. finding the house key to number 55 had since been put in the meter box.
因为他的工作要求全家紧急搬迁到澳大利亚。因为他的工作要求全家紧急搬迁到澳大利亚。类似的信件也送达了阿涅斯的工作场所、阿瑟工作的比萨店，以及他和托马斯就读的学院，所有这些都证实了这家人突然出国。在收到这封令人费解的信后，阿涅斯的上司试图给她打电话，在收到这封令人费解的信后，阿涅斯的上司试图给她打电话，但没有回应。整个星期有几个人试图联系这家人，但都无济于事，他们的Facebook账户仍然处于不活动状态。两名亲戚访问了罗伯特·舒曼大道进行调查，发现55号的房子钥匙此后已经放回电表箱里。发现55号的房子钥匙此后已经放回电表箱里。
Upon entering the home, they too noticed its seemingly deserted state, with police examining the property soon after when concerns had peaked. A missing persons file was officially opened for Xavier, Agnes, Arthur, Thomas, Anne and Benoit Dupont de Léganès, with news of their mysterious disappearance broadcast locally. Investigators searching for the missing family looked into their finances and realised that while the close-knit household appeared well-off, they were heavily in debt. In 2003, Xavier had used the majority of Vanyus' sizable inheritance to register a series of businesses, but none garnered much success and recorded more debt than revenue.
进入家门后，他们也注意到了它看似荒凉的状态，在疑虑达到顶峰后不久警察检查了该物业。正式为泽维尔、阿涅斯、阿瑟、托马斯、安妮和伯努瓦·杜邦·德·利戈内斯立案失踪人员档案，他们神秘失踪的消息在当地广播。寻找失踪家庭的调查人员调查了他们的财务状况，并意识到虽然这个紧密团结的家庭看起来很富有，但他们负债累累。2003年，泽维尔动用了瓦纽斯（Vanyus）相当可观的大部分遗产来注册了一系列企业，但没有一家获得太大成功，记录的债务多于收入。
The first, NetSurf concept, was registered in Miami following his family's trip to the United States and was intended to be a hotel and restaurant guide for truckers, travelling salespeople, and their employers. The second, Selref, was registered in France and provided corporate clients with a hotel, restaurant, and conference centre verification service. Xavier travelled across France, staying in hotels using a fake identity to vet the establishments himself. His third business endeavour, Route de Commerce U, referred to in his letter, was the French version of the NetServe concept. There were also a couple of other businesses Xavier had registered, but never activated. Almost all of his companies had laid dormant
第一家网瑟概念（NetSurf concept）在家人去美国旅行后在迈阿密注册，旨在成为卡车司机、旅行推销员及其雇主的酒店和餐厅指南。第二家赛尔雷夫（Selref）在法国注册，为企业客户提供酒店、餐厅和会议中心验证服务。泽维尔游历法国各地，用假身份住在酒店里亲自审查这些场所。他的第三个商业努力，即信中提到的“商业路线U”，是网瑟概念的法国版本。泽维尔还注册了其他一些企业，但从未启动过。几乎他所有的公司都处于休眠状态
for several years, and between 2004 and 2009, he was officially registered as unemployed. In 2009, tax records indicated the Dupont de Léganès household had earned a total income of just over 5,000 euros, followed by 4,000 euros in 2010. Their house rent cost 18,000 euros per annum and this didn't include living expenses, bills, food or school fees, so Xavier sought loans from relatives and friends to make ends meet. He had also opened multiple bank accounts and credit cards in different names. Police searched the missing family's property again on Tuesday April 19 and found several receipts for suspicious items purchased in the weeks leading up to their disappearance, including large garbage bags, a box of adhesive plastic paving slabs, cement, a shovel, a hoe,
多年来，在2004年至2009年间，他被官方登记为失业。2009年，税务记录显示，杜邦·德·利戈内斯一家的总收入刚刚超过5000欧元，2010年为4000欧元。他们的房租每年18000欧元，这还不包括生活费、账单、食物或学费，因此泽维尔向亲戚和朋友寻求贷款以维持生计。他还以不同的名字开立了多个银行账户和信用卡。警方于4月19日星期二再次搜查了失踪家庭的财产，并发现了他们在失踪前几周购买的可疑物品的几张收据，包括大垃圾袋、一盒粘性塑料地砖、水泥、一把铁锹、一把锄头，
and four 10kg bags of lime. The lime, which had been purchased from several different stores throughout Nantes, was of particular interest. Also known as calcium oxide, lime is a chemical compound that prevents odour and is widely, incorrectly, believed to speed up the decomposition of human remains. On Thursday April 21, Robert Schuman Boulevard was closed off as detectives armed with a search warrant entered number 55. The investigators responsible for carrying out this search noted the house was messier than their colleagues had previously led them to believe, with garbage bags full of clothing in the bedrooms and various items scattered about.
以及四袋10公斤的生石灰。生石灰从南特的几家不同的商店购买，引起了特别的兴趣。生石灰又称氧化钙，是一种防止异味的化合物，人们普遍错误地认为它可以加速人类遗骸的分解。4月21日星期四，罗伯特舒曼大道被封锁，手持搜查令的侦探进入了55号。负责执行这次搜查的调查人员指出，房子比他们的同事之前让他们相信的要凌乱，卧室里装满衣服的垃圾袋和各种物品散落各处。
Documents appeared to be missing, as was Xavier's desktop computer, the family's computer, cell phones, hard drives and USB sticks. In a bathroom cabinet, detectives found several opened bottles of medication to treat depression and anxiety. Despite the house being in slight disarray, it was otherwise clean and contained no rubbish. Several empty bottles of cleaning liquids, scrubbing brushes, a mop and a broom indicated it had recently been given a thorough clean. A rear door led out to a small terrace that overlooked an unkempt backyard garden consisting of a patch of dirt and some sprouting weeds. In Xavier's letter, he had specifically told his friends and family to ignore several bulky items stored underneath the terrace, claiming they were there when the family moved in.
文件似乎不见了，泽维尔的台式电脑、家里的电脑、手机、硬盘和Uusb闪存盘也是如此。在浴室柜里，侦探们发现了几个打开的治疗抑郁症和焦虑症的药物瓶。尽管房子有点凌乱，但它在其他方面很干净，不包含垃圾。几瓶空的清洁液体、洗涤刷、拖把和扫帚表明它最近得到了彻底的清洁。后门通向一个小露台，俯瞰着一个疏于打理的后院花园，花园里有一块泥土和一些发芽的杂草。在泽维尔的信中，他明确告诉他的朋友和家人忽略露台下存放的几个笨重的物品，声称他们搬进来时就在那里。
But an officer searching the yard noticed something out of place. Several plywood boards had been fastened to the right-hand side of the terrace, blocking access to underneath the house. Some boards were also lying on the ground and soil around them appeared to be fresh. The officer picked up one of the boards, finding a dog bowl. She brushed aside some of the loose soil and discovered cement that had not quite set. It crumbled when she dug her nails into it and she began digging until her fingers came into contact with something soft. She moved the crumbled cement aside, exposing a human leg. exposing a human leg. Forensic investigators conducted a thorough search under the terrace, which at its tallest point was only 120 centimetres high. In the location where the
但一名搜查院子的警官注意到有什么不对劲。几块合板被固定在露台的右侧，阻碍了通往房屋下方的通道。一些木板也躺在地上，它们周围的泥土似乎是新鲜的。警官拿起一块木板，发现了一个狗碗。她拨开一些松散的土，发现了尚未完全凝固的水泥。当她把指甲挖进去时，它碎了，她开始挖，直到她的手指接触到柔软的东西。她把碎水泥拨到一边，露出一只人腿。露出一只人腿。法医调查人员对露台下方进行了彻底的搜查，露台最高处只有120厘米高。在那个位置
officer had found the leg, they came across a layer of powdered lime. They dug deeper, They dug deeper, revealing the rest of the body, followed by three others. They were identified as 48-year-old Agnes Dupont de Léganès and three of her children, 20-year-old Arthur, 16-year-old Anne, and 13-year-old Benoit. Buried with them were the family's two Labradors. Agnes' remaining son, 18-year-old Thomas, was found buried in a separate pit to the left-hand side of the terrace. Each victim was dressed for bed and had been wrapped in a sheet or blanket, along with a Virgin Mary figurine, a crucifix necklace, or a set of rosary beads.
警官发现了那条腿，他们遇到了粉状石灰层。他们挖得更深，他们挖得更深，露出了身体的其余部分，接着是其他三个。他们被确认是48岁的阿涅斯·杜邦·德·利戈内斯和她的三个孩子，20岁的阿瑟、16岁的安妮和13岁的伯努瓦。与他们埋在一起的是家里的两只拉布拉多犬。阿涅斯剩下的儿子、18岁的托马斯被发现埋在露台左侧的一个独立坑里。每个受害者都穿着睡衣，并用床单或毯子包裹着，连同一个圣母玛利亚雕像、一个耶稣受难十字架项链或一串玫瑰经念珠。
merry figurine, a crucifix necklace, or a set of rosary beads. They were placed inside individual garbage bags, with their heads resting against blood-stained pillows. Bullet shells belonging to a.22 calibre long rifle were also found inside the bags. Autopsies revealed each victim had been shot at close range, likely with the muzzle of the rifle pressed against their bodies. Agnes, Arthur and Dan had been shot twice in the head. So had Thomas, but he had also been shot twice in the chest. Youngest child, Benoit, had sustained the most wounds, three to the head and another two to the chest. The family dogs had also been shot. None of the victims exhibited defensive wounds, indicating they had likely been asleep at the time they were killed.
快乐的小雕像，一个十字架项链，或一组玫瑰经念珠。他们被放在各自的垃圾袋里，头部靠在沾满血迹的枕头上。袋子里还发现了属于.22口径长步枪的子弹壳。尸检显示，每个受害者都在近距离内被枪击，枪口很可能紧贴着他们的身体。阿涅斯、阿瑟和丹头部中了两枪。托马斯也是如此，但他的胸部也中了两枪。最小的孩子伯努瓦受了最多的伤，头部三处，胸部另外两处。家里的狗也被枪杀了。受害者都没有表现出防御性伤病，这表明他们在被杀时可能已经睡着了。
Toxicology tests revealed trace amounts of sleeping pills in each victim except Agnes, implying the children had been drugged before their deaths. Small amounts of human and animal blood was found on a mop, a bucket and on a chair in the kitchen. No fingerprints were detected on the bodies of the victims, nor the materials they were wrapped in. It appeared as though the five murders had been committed inside the home, with the perpetrator going to great lengths to clean the crime scene. The coroner was unable to determine an exact date of death, but estimated the family had died between 10 and 21 days prior to the discovery of their remains. Phone records showed Anne had sent a text
毒理学测试显示，除了阿涅斯之外，每个受害者的体内都有微量的安眠药，这意味着孩子们在死前被下了药。在拖把、水桶和厨房的椅子上发现了少量的血迹。在受害者的尸体上没有检测到指纹，也没有在他们包裹的材料上检测到。这五起谋杀案似乎是在屋内犯下的，凶手竭尽全力清理犯罪现场。法医无法确定准确的死亡日期，但估计这家人在发现遗骸前10到21天之间死亡。电话记录显示安妮发了一条短信
to a friend at 12.30am on Monday April 4 and an analysis of Agnes' sleep apnea machine, used to help her breathe at night, showed it stopped working a few hours later at 3.30am. Agnes was likely killed around this time time before the perpetrator went into the bedrooms of Arthur, Anne and Benoit and executed them one at a time, followed by the dogs. They were then buried together under the terrace before the perpetrator went about meticulously cleaning the crime scene. Thomas wasn't home at the time his mother and siblings were slaughtered, though he was summoned to the house the following evening of Tuesday April 5 by his father and was likely murdered and buried that night. His bout of illness while dining with Xavier the evening
在4月4日星期一凌晨12点30分给一个朋友，对阿涅斯用于帮助她夜间呼吸的睡眠呼吸暂停机的分析显示，它在几小时后的3点30分停止工作。阿涅斯很可能在此时左右被杀，然后凶手进入阿瑟、安妮和伯努瓦的卧室，一个接一个地处决了他们，接着是狗。然后他们被一起埋在露台下，然后凶手开始煞费苦心地清理犯罪现场。托马斯在母亲和兄弟姐妹被屠杀时不在家，尽管他在第二天4月5日星期二晚上被父亲传唤到家里，可能在那晚被谋杀并埋葬。他在前一天晚上与泽维尔进餐时生病
before might have been a reaction to sleeping pills that were planted in his meal, though his murder didn't go ahead until the following night, for reasons unknown. The whereabouts of the deceased family's patriarch, Xavier Dupont de Ligones, remained unknown, despite ample sightings of the man and continued communications from him up until he mailed out his written send-off. Emerging as the prime suspect, it appeared that in the days following the murders, Xavier contacted his family's schools and workplaces and used their phones to text concerned friends to evade suspicions over their absence. He then fabricated a story about being placed into witness protection in an effort to justify their permanent disappearance. A press conference was held immediately, during which a public
之前可能是对饭菜里被下的安眠药的反应，尽管由于不明原因，他的谋杀直到第二天晚上才进行。已故家庭家长泽维尔·杜邦·德·利戈内斯的下落仍然不明，尽管有大量关于此人的目击情报，并且在他寄出书面的送别信之前，他一直与外界保持联系。作为头号嫌疑人，似乎在谋杀发生后的几天里，泽维尔联系了家人的学校和工作场所，并用他们的手机给担心的朋友发短信，以逃避对他们缺席的怀疑。然后，他编造了一个被置于证人保护之下的故事，以证明他们永久失踪的合理性。立即举行了新闻发布会，期间公开
prosecutor described the murders as a methodical execution and called the content of Xavier's farewell letter delusional and contradictory. An investigation was already underway to find him, with police utilising an automatic number plate recognition system that enabled them to track down Xavier Citroen C5. It was located in a hotel car park in the coastal town of Roquebrune-sur-Argent, just over 1,000 kilometres southeast of Nantes. The car was abandoned and Xavier himself was nowhere to be seen. News of the slayings had made national headlines. A majority of the media stories disputed the possibility that Xavier had been working headlines. A majority of the media stories disputed the possibility that Xavier had been working as a covert DEA agent, although some entertained the
检察官将谋杀案描述为有条不紊的处决，并称泽维尔的告别信内容妄想且自相矛盾。搜寻他的调查工作已经在进行中，警方利用了自动车牌识别系统，使他们能够追踪到泽维尔的雪铁龙C5。它位于罗克布吕讷-叙尔阿尔让（Roquebrune-sur-Argens）沿海小镇的一家酒店停车场，位于南特东南略多1000公里处。这辆车被遗弃了，泽维尔本人无影无踪。谋杀案的消息上了全国头条新闻。大多数媒体报道反驳了泽维尔作为秘密DEA特工工作的可能性，尽管一些媒体也接受了这一观点。媒体报道反驳了泽维尔作为秘密DEA特工工作的可能性，尽管一些媒体也接受了这一观点。
idea. Members of Xavier's extended family told reporters they believed he was innocent and being held hostage somewhere against his will. His sister, Christine, made an appearance on national radio station RTL, urging her brother to come forward to police if this was not the case. She acknowledged there were many signs pointing towards her brother's guilt, but described him as a doting and affectionate father incapable of committing the crimes. father incapable of committing the crimes. Agnes' family also spoke publicly, declaring they would not pass judgement until Xavier was found and could explain himself. Meanwhile, a woman named Catherine had come forward to police,
泽维尔的远亲告诉记者，他们相信他是无辜的，在某个地方违背他的意愿被劫为人质。他的姐姐克里斯蒂娜出现在全国广播电台RTL上，敦促她的哥哥如果不是这样的话，就向警方自首。她承认有很多迹象表明她哥哥有罪，但形容他是一个慈爱且深情的父亲，不可能犯下这些罪行。父亲不可能犯下这些罪行。阿涅斯的家人也公开表态，宣称在找到泽维尔并能够解释清楚之前，他们不会妄加评判。与此同时，一名叫凯瑟琳（Catherine）的女子向警方报案，
declaring that she and Xavier had recently ended a two-year-long affair. Her claims were substantiated by text and email communication between the pair, who had dated as teenagers and reconnected online in 2008. Xavier was going through a difficult period at the time, as his father had suffered an embolism and the affair began soon after. In late 2009, at Xavier's request, Catherine provided him with a loan of 50,000 euros, with Xavier promising to leave his family for her. He failed to do so and in January of 2010, he emailed Catherine explaining he was quote, at the bottom of the hole and asked her to save him by providing another loan. She refused, requesting he repay the money she had already lent
宣称她和泽维尔最近结束了一段长达两年的婚外情。她的说法得到了两人之间短信和电子邮件通讯的证实，两人在青少年时期曾约会，并于2008年在网上重新建立联系。当时泽维尔正经历一段艰难时期，因为他的父亲患了栓塞，婚外情不久后就开始了。在2009年底，应泽维尔的要求，凯瑟琳向他提供了50,000欧元的贷款，泽维尔承诺为她离开他的家人。他没有这样做，并在2010年1月给凯瑟琳发了一封电子邮件，解释说他引用“在洞底”，并要求她通过提供另一笔贷款来拯救他。她拒绝了，要求他偿还她已经借出的钱
him. Xavier replied that he was three months behind on rent and only had 500 euros for the family's food that month, with the government chasing him for tax payments. In further emails, Xavier said he suffered from insomnia, anxiety attacks and was plagued by morbid ideas. He claimed he was no longer in love with his wife and entertained the idea of drugging his family with sleeping pills before setting their house on fire. He also suggested throwing himself in front of a truck so that Agnes would benefit from his 600,000 euro life insurance policy. Catherine broke things off with Xavier later that year and in early 2011, she began legal proceedings to recover
他。泽维尔回答说，他已经拖欠了三个月的房租，那个月家里只剩下500欧元的餐费，税务部门还在催他缴税。在随后的电子邮件中，泽维尔称自己患有失眠症和焦虑发作，并深受病态念头的困扰。他声称自己不再爱妻子，并萌生了用安眠药迷晕家人然后放火烧房子的想法。他还建议把自己扔在一辆卡车前面，这样阿格尼斯就能从他60万欧元的寿险保单中受益。凯瑟琳在那年晚些时候与泽维尔断绝了关系，并在2011年早些时候开始通过法律程序追讨
the money she had loaned him. Catherine's legal counsel ordered a bailiff to attend the Dupont de Ligonais home to provide a valuation of their possessions. When the bailiff visited the property on the morning of Tuesday April 5, no one answered the door. Four days later, on Saturday April 9, Catherine received a letter from Xavier which included the line, We had a good time together, but now you will know misfortune. It became increasingly clear that the image Xavier and Agnes presented to the outside world was starkly different to what went on behind closed doors. Interviews with friends and family revealed that in 2005,
他借给他的钱。凯瑟琳的法律顾问指派了一名法警前往杜蓬·德·利戈内斯的住所，对他们的财产进行估价。当法警于4月5日星期二上午访问该物业时，没有人应门。四天后，即4月9日星期六，凯瑟琳收到了一封来自泽维尔的信，其中有一行字：“我们度过了一段美好的时光，但现在你将经历不幸。”越来越明显的是，泽维尔和阿格尼斯向外界展示的形象与他们关起门来的生活有着天壤之别。对朋友和家人的采访显示，在2005年，
Agnes had developed a close relationship with one of Xavier's best friends. The two embarked on an emotional affair, exchanging texts and long phone calls. During this period, Xavier's work required him to be away from home for long stretches at a time, which led Agnes to suspect he was also being unfaithful. When Xavier found out about his wife's emotional affair, the pair separated, only to patch things up six months later and resume their marriage. They sent a detailed letter to their friends and family in which Agnes accepted blame for their temporary breakup and praised Xavier as a wonderful husband. Xavier expressed a desire to absolve the
阿格尼斯与泽维尔的一位挚友建立了亲密关系。两人展开了一段精神出轨，互发短信并进行长时间的电话交谈。在此期间，泽维尔的工作要求他长时间离家在外，这导致阿格尼斯怀疑他也对婚姻不忠。当泽维尔发现妻子精神出轨后，两人分居了，但在六个月后又重修旧好，恢复了婚姻。他们向朋友和家人发了一封详细的信，信中阿格尼斯承认了他们暂时分居的责任，并赞美泽维尔是一个极好的丈夫。泽维尔表达了想要消除
negative image their loved ones might have developed as a result of Agnes bad-mouthing him. Agnes' family reported that she had grown frustrated with the amount of time Xavier spent away and had been contemplating leaving him. Yet, there were also reports to the contrary. A close friend said Xavier loved Agnes deeply and always hurried home on Friday afternoons so they could attend square dancing classes together. The family had recently vacationed in the south of France for a family wedding and Xavier's aunt told the media the husband and wife, quote, held hands and gave the impression of being perfectly happy.
由于阿格尼斯说他的坏话而可能在亲人心中产生的负面形象的愿望。阿格尼斯的家人报告说，她对泽维尔在外奔波的时间感到厌烦，并一直在考虑离开他。然而，也有相反的报道。一位密友说，泽维尔深爱着阿格尼斯，总是在周五下午匆忙赶回家，这样他们就可以一起去上方块舞课。这家人最近去法国南部度假参加了一个家庭婚礼，泽维尔的姑姑告诉媒体，这对夫妇“手拉着手，给人一种非常幸福的印象”。
One close friend and confidant maintained Agnes was still madly in love with Xavier. In addition to the mounting financial troubles and infidelity, the couple were also heading in different spiritual directions. Agnes was a devout Catholic and extremely pious, attending mass every Sunday. Xavier had distanced himself from religion in his adult years and was furious when his wife paid a Catholic guru 3,000 euros for his services. Agnes's priest told investigators that she regularly sought advice about the strong tensions in her marriage when it came to religion. He felt the troubles between Agnes and Xavier were significant enough that divorce seemed inevitable.
一位密友兼知己坚信阿格尼斯依然疯狂地爱着泽维尔。除了不断增加的财务困境和不忠之外，这对夫妇在精神信仰上也走向了不同的方向。阿格尼斯是一位虔诚的天主教徒，极其笃信宗教，每个星期天都去望弥撒。泽维尔在成年后已经疏远了宗教，当他的妻子向一位天主教大师支付3,000欧元的服务费时，他勃然大怒。阿格尼斯的牧师告诉调查人员，她经常就婚姻中因宗教而产生的强烈紧张关系寻求建议。他觉得阿格尼斯和泽维尔之间的麻烦已经严重到离婚似乎不可避免的地步。
Agnes and Xavier were significant enough that divorce seemed inevitable. It was discovered that in the months leading up to the murders, Xavier had visited a shooting range in Nantes. He had enrolled for shooting lessons in December 2010, telling staff he would soon be inheriting his father's.22 calibre long rifle and wanted to obtain his firearms licence. He attended several lessons and received his licence in February 2011, around the time he inherited the rifle. From there on in, he attended the range regularly, usually hiring a weapon from the venue but occasionally bringing his rifle. He raised little concern from staff, appearing friendly and always smiling, although his rifle was fitted with a silencer, which was generally frowned upon. Receipts confirmed Zabier had purchased the silencer along with ammunition a month before the murders.
阿格尼斯和泽维尔之间的问题已经严重到离婚似乎不可避免的地步。据发现，在谋杀案发生前的几个月里，泽维尔曾参观过南特的一个射击场。他在2010年12月报名参加了射击课程，告诉工作人员他很快将继承他父亲的.22口径长步枪，并希望获得枪支执照。他参加了多次课程，并于2011年2月获得了执照，大约在他继承那支步枪的时候。从那时起，他经常去射击场，通常是从场地租用武器，但偶尔也会带上他的步枪。他很少引起工作人员的担忧，表现得很友好并且总是面带微笑，尽管他的步枪装有消音器，这通常是不受欢迎的。收据证实，扎维尔在谋杀案发生前一个月购买了消音器以及弹药。
In the lead-up to April 4, he attended the range four times in quick succession, on March 26, 28, 30 and April 1. On the final visit, he brought Thomas and Benoit with him, who had recently started lessons of their own. brought Thomas and Benoit with him, who had recently started lessons of their own. The three usually ended their practice with a drink, but this time they told their instructor they didn't have time to stick around, as they had other plans. On Tuesday April 26, several hundred people gathered in central Nantes to participate in a silent march in honour of Agnès, Arthur, Thomas, Anne and Benoît Dupont de Léganès. They walked with the deceased's friends and family to 55 Robert Schumann Boulevard, leaving flowers on the street out front. Agnès' car was still parked on
在4月4日之前，他连续四次快速前往靶场，分别是3月26日、28日、30日和4月1日。在最后一次访问时，他带上了托马斯和伯努瓦，他们最近也开始了自己的课程。带上了托马斯和伯努瓦，他们最近也开始了自己的课程。这三个人通常以喝一杯结束他们的练习，但这次他们告诉教练他们没有时间逗留，因为他们还有其他计划。4月26日星期二，数百人聚集在南特市中心，参加静默游行，以纪念阿格尼斯、亚瑟、托马斯、安妮和伯努瓦·杜蓬·德·莱加内斯。他们与死者的亲友一起步行到罗伯特·舒曼大道55号，在街头前方的地面上献上鲜花。阿格尼斯的车仍停在
a nearby street, with one mourner riding in the dust that had gathered on it. You had no right. We miss you. A funeral service was held days later, with the streets around the church closed to traffic to facilitate the crowds of mourners. Loudspeakers broadcast the service to the hundreds outside who couldn't fit inside the building as individual black hearses transported the five wooden coffins to the church. black hearses transported the five wooden coffins to the church. Stories were shared fondly by their loved ones, with a member of Agnes' family addressing the friends of the children directly, quoting Pope Benedict XVI, Fear not. Believe in the strength of life and of love.
附近的街道上，一名哀悼者在上面积聚的灰尘写下了字。你们没有权力。我们想念你们。几天后举行了葬礼，教堂周围的街道禁止车辆通行，以便容纳成群的哀悼者。扩音器向外面无法挤进建筑物的数百人广播了葬礼服务，同时一辆辆黑色的灵车将五具木棺运送到教堂。黑色的灵车将五具木棺运送到教堂。亲人们深情地分享了他们的故事，阿格尼斯的一位家属直接向孩子们的朋辈发表了讲话，引用教皇本笃十六世的话：“不要害怕。要相信生命和爱的力量。”
Agnes was laid to rest with her four children in an ancestral tomb in the town where her birth family originated. Locating the surviving member of the family, Xavier Dupont de Léganès, had become the number one priority. Authorities were able to piece together his movements in the days following the murders through credit card records, witness reports, CCTV footage, and highway monitoring systems. By the early afternoon of Sunday April 10, Xavier had cleared out both Arthur and Thomas' dorm rooms, with the latter's belongings found in dumpsters nearby. After travelling 90 kilometres south, he stopped to eat lunch at a restaurant, where his mixed demeanour was noted as both seemingly relaxed, yet in a hurry. By that evening, he had checked into a hotel in the town of Puil Boho,
阿格尼斯和她的四个孩子一起被安葬在其娘家发源地的祖墓中。寻找家族中幸存的成员泽维尔·杜蓬·德·莱加内斯已成为首要任务。通过信用卡记录、目击者报告、闭路电视监控画面以及高速公路监控系统，当局得以拼凑出他在谋杀案发生后几天的行踪。到4月10日星期日中午过后不久，泽维尔已经清理了亚瑟和托马斯的宿舍房间，后者的物品在附近的垃圾箱里被找到。在向南行驶了90公里后，他在一家餐馆停下来吃午饭，他那混杂的举止被注意到，既显得放松，又行色匆匆。到了那天晚上，他在皮尔博霍镇的一家酒店登记入住，
where he dined on steak and red wine. The next day, he drove 420 kilometres southeast to the town of Blagnac, where he stayed in a hotel overnight. He then drove 350 kilometres east to the town of La Ponte and checked into a five-star inn, registering under the alias Mr Lohan Xavier, with his profession listed as businessman. He chatted openly and confidently with staff and tried flirting with the hotel manager, telling them he was in the area looking for professional contacts. He ate dinner at the hotel restaurant and used a computer at their in-house internet cafe to search for information about a controversial Catholic institution called Opus Dei. The next morning, Xavier continued 160 kilometres southeast to the Mediterranean coastal town of La Seine-sur-Mer, where he had lived briefly before his marriage
在那里他享用了牛排和红酒。第二天，他向东南驱车420公里来到布拉尼亚克镇，并在一家酒店过夜。然后他向东驱车350公里来到拉庞特镇，入住了一家五星级客栈，以罗汉·泽维尔先生（Mr Lohan Xavier）的化名登记，职业栏填的是商人。他与工作人员公开而自信地交谈，并试图调戏酒店经理，告诉他们他是在该地区寻找专业联系人。他在酒店餐厅吃了晚饭，并使用他们内部网吧的电脑搜索了关于一个名为“主业会”（Opus Dei）的有争议的天主教机构的信息。第二天早上，泽维尔继续向东南行驶160公里，来到了地中海沿岸城镇滨海拉塞讷，他在与阿格尼斯结婚前曾在那里短暂居住过。
to Agnès. He spent the night in a low-budget hotel before travelling onwards 91 kilometres northeast to the town of Roquebrune-sur-Argence, an hour from the Italian border. He was familiar with the area, having lived there with his family for two years in the 90s. There, Xavier, dressed in a dark long-sleeved sweater, light-coloured pants and eyeglasses, was captured on CCTV using an ATM to withdraw 30 euros, the maximum remaining on his monthly withdrawal limit. He checked into another budget hotel and at 8.40pm emailed his friend Vincent, whom he had given ownership of his business websites a week earlier. He claimed the Route de Commerce U business website had been infiltrated by a virus
他在一家经济型酒店过夜，然后继续向东北行驶91公里，前往距离意大利边境一小时车程的罗克布吕讷-叙尔-阿尔让镇。他对该地区很熟悉，90年代曾和家人在那里生活过两年。在那里，穿着深色长袖毛衣、浅色裤子并戴着眼镜的泽维尔被闭路电视拍到，他正在使用自动取款机提取30欧元，这是他每月取款限额剩下的最大额度。他入住另一家经济型酒店，并在晚上8点40分给他的朋友文森特发了电子邮件，一周前他刚刚把自己的商业网站的所有权交给了对方。他声称“商业之路”（Route de Commerce U）商业网站遭到病毒入侵，
and the site had subsequently been deleted. On Friday April 15, Xavier checked out of the hotel and abandoned his Citroen C5 in the car park. As he exited the establishment, wearing a backpack and carrying a duffel bag, he turned and looked directly towards a CCTV camera located at the front of the building. Investigators interpreted this look as one of defiance or some sort of a goodbye. Investigators interpreted this look as one of defiance or some sort of a goodbye. That evening, the theft of a license plate from the parking lot where Xavier had left his car was reported to police. From that point onwards, the trail went cold. The town itself was home to several small chapels, leading to the possibility that Xavier had chosen the area for a religious pilgrimage.
并且该网站随后已被删除。4月15日星期五，泽维尔办理了退房手续，并将他的雪铁龙C5遗弃在停车场。当他背着背包、提着行李袋走出这家机构时，他转过身，直视着位于建筑物正前方的闭路电视摄像头。调查人员将这种注视解读为一种蔑视或某种形式的告别。调查人员将这种注视解读为一种蔑视或某种形式的告别。那天晚上，警方接到报案称，泽维尔留车的停车场发生了一起车牌被盗事件。从那时起，线索就中断了。该镇本身拥有几座小型教堂，这导致了一种可能性，即泽维尔选择该地区是为了进行宗教朝圣。
Police searched a wooded location 500 metres from the hotel, covering an area of 25 square kilometres, but no trace of Xavier was found. Xavier was found. Unsubstantiated sightings placed him in the coastal city of Nice near the Italian border, driving a sedan with Paris licence plates. Some witnesses claimed he was alone, while others put him in the company of a blonde woman. Media speculated over the identity of Xavier's alleged female companion and drew a connection to a missing woman named Corlette de Romme. The 50-year-old disappeared from her home in the town of Logue, 30 kilometres west of Roquebrune-sur-Argence, the same day Xavier was last sighted. Xavier and Agnes had lived in Logue for a while in the early 90s and their home had been just 500 metres from Corlette's. Reporters wondered if Xavier and Corlette had known each other previously
警方搜查了距离酒店500米的一个林木茂密的地方，搜查面积达25平方公里，但没有找到泽维尔的任何踪迹。泽维尔没有被找到。未经证实的目击报告称，他在靠近意大利边境的海滨城市尼斯看到，驾驶着一辆挂着巴黎牌照的轿车。一些目击者称他独自一人，而另一些则称他与一名金发女子同行。媒体猜测泽维尔所谓的女性同伴的身份，并将其与一名名为科莱特·德·罗姆的失踪女子联系起来。这位50岁的女子在泽维尔最后一次被目击的当天，从罗盖镇（距离罗克布吕讷-叙尔-阿尔让以西30公里）的家中失踪。泽维尔和阿格尼斯曾在90年代初在罗盖住过一段时间，他们的家距离科莱特的家只有500米。记者们想知道泽维尔和科莱特以前是否认识
and were hiding together, but investigators were certain there was no connection and were proven correct when Corlette was found deceased and her sister-in-law and sister-in-law's son were charged with her murder. Xavier's motive to kill his entire family was theorised to have been a blend of personal and professional issues in his life, with his father's death in January 2011 acting as the catalyst. Yet, such crimes were usually triggered by upcoming events rather than ones that occurred in the past. Psychiatrists concluded Xavier was a narcissist who couldn't bear to sully the Dupont-DeLeganès name with financial or marital failures. The crime appeared to be a classic case of family annihilation,
并藏匿在一起，但调查人员确信没有任何联系，当科莱特被发现身亡且其小姑子和小姑子的儿子被指控谋杀她时，事实证明调查人员是对的。泽维尔杀害全家的动机被理论化为他生活中个人和职业问题的交织，2011年1月他父亲的去世起到了催化剂的作用。然而，此类犯罪通常是由即将发生的事件引发的，而不是过去发生的事件。精神病学家得出结论，泽维尔是一个自恋狂，无法忍受杜蓬-德莱加内斯这个姓氏被财务或婚姻失败所玷污。这起犯罪似乎是一起典型的灭门惨案，
also known as familicide. According to criminologist Professor David Wilson, male family annihilators act for one of four reasons. To enact revenge on the mother, to punish the family for not living up to his ideals, to protect the family from what he perceives to be an external threat, or because he views the family as a status symbol that no longer serves this function upon his own economic failure. Speaking about his research to Wired magazine, Professor Wilson said, What's interesting and different about this category of murderer is family annihilators were overwhelmingly not known to criminal justice or mental health services.
也被称为家族谋杀。根据犯罪学家大卫·威尔逊教授的说法，男性灭门凶手采取行动的原因有四种之一：对母亲实施报复、惩罚家人未能达到他的理想、保护家人免受他认为的外部威胁，或者因为他将家人视为一个地位象征，而在他经济破产时，这个象征不再发挥这种功能。威尔逊教授在接受《连线》杂志采访时谈到他的研究时说：“这类杀手有趣且不同寻常的地方在于，绝大多数灭门凶手并不为刑事司法或心理健康服务机构所知。”
For all intents and purposes, these were loving husbands and good fathers, often holding down high-profile jobs and seen publicly as being very, very successful. They were simply not on the radar. On Tuesday May 10, an international arrest warrant was issued, meaning French officials would have the right to indict Xavier and put him on trial, even in absentia. By May 12, approximately 330 calls had come in from the public reporting possible sightings of Xavier throughout France, Italy, and as far away as Austria, though none proved credible. There were deliberations the fugitive was being harboured by a family member, yet search warrants came up empty. yet search warrants came up empty. As did inquiries into a former business associate of Xavier's,
出于所有意图和目的，这些都是深爱妻子的丈夫和优秀的父亲，通常拥有高调的工作，在公众看来非常非常成功。他们根本不在雷达范围内。5月10日星期二，国际刑警组织发出国际逮捕令，这意味着法国官员将有权起诉泽维尔并对其实施审判，哪怕是在缺席的情况下。截至5月12日，公众共打来约330通电话，报告在法国、意大利甚至远至奥地利发现泽维尔的可能踪迹，但没有一个被证明是可靠的。有讨论称这名逃犯受到某位家庭成员的庇护，然而搜查令却一无所获。搜查令却一无所获。对泽维尔的一位前商业伙伴的调查也是如此，
who helped his clients obtain anonymous bank cards that could be used worldwide without leaving a trace. It was speculated that Xavier may have employed these services to create a new identity and disappear, but investigators uncovered no evidence to support this theory. Zabier's links to a prayer group his mother founded called Philadelphia were also explored. Zabier had reportedly been involved with the group, which had been accused of being sectarian and cult-like in the past, and some suspected the group may be assisting him. and cult-like in the past and some suspected the group may be assisting him. Investigators visited group members, seizing computers, hard drives and mobile phone records, but failed to uncover any direct links to their suspect. As Xavier remained completely hidden over the following months, speculation arose that he may have ended his own life shortly after
他曾帮助客户获得可在全球范围内使用且不留痕迹的匿名银行卡。据推测，泽维尔可能利用了这些服务来创造新身份并隐匿起来，但调查人员没有发现任何支持这一理论的证据。扎维尔与他母亲创立的一个名为“费城”的祈祷团体的联系也被探讨了。据报道，扎维尔曾参与过这个团体，该团体过去曾被指控具有宗派色彩和邪教特征，有些人怀疑该团体可能在协助他。且具有邪教特征，有些人怀疑该团体可能在协助他。调查人员走访了该团体的成员，查封了电脑、硬盘和手机记录，但未能发现与他们的嫌疑人的任何直接联系。随着泽维尔在接下来的几个月里彻底销声匿迹，人们开始猜测他可能在
carrying out the murders. The public prosecutors believed this was the most likely outcome, but many disagreed, arguing that he wouldn't have gone to such extreme lengths to plot his escape if he intended to take his own life. Xavier's computer had been wiped clean, but the French cyber police were able to retrieve data stored on an external server hosted by the family's internet provider. They recovered hundreds of emails, photos, and texts dated between 2006 and 2010. There were emails addressed to Catherine, Xavier's former lover, and several other women, indicating he had participated in other affairs. He maintained his habit of borrowing money from them while making false promises about the future. At one stage, he wrote about his wife's affair, quote,
实施谋杀后不久就结束了自己的生命。检察官认为这是最可能的结果，但许多人不同意，他们认为如果他打算自杀，就不会大费周章地策划逃跑。泽维尔的电脑被彻底抹除了，但法国网络警察能够从该家庭互联网服务商托管的外部服务器上恢复存储的数据。他们恢复了数百封电子邮件、照片和短信，日期介于2006年至2010年之间。其中有写给凯瑟琳（泽维尔的前情人）以及其他几位女性的电子邮件，表明他曾参与过其他外遇。他保持着向她们借钱的习惯，同时对未来做出虚假的承诺。在一个阶段，他写到了他妻子的外遇，引用：
I was lucky to have found a woman emotionally and sexually faithful. I was naive and confident, gullible. Realising after 15 years of marriage that it was not so, that she had physical desires of other men, was the greatest personal disappointment imaginable. Throughout 2010, Xavier made hundreds of posts under multiple usernames to an online forum titled SeatCatholique.org in which he questioned God and his faith. Around a year before the murders, he started a thread titled Necessity of Sacrifices and participated in a heated debate with other users. He said, The concept of sacrifice, bloody or not, human or animal, is intrinsically linked to all religions, and especially ours.
“我很幸运能找到一个在情感和生理上都忠诚的女性。我曾那么天真、自信、轻信。在结婚15年后意识到事实并非如此，意识到她对其他男人有着身体上的渴望，这是可以想象到的最大的个人失望。”整个2010年，泽维尔在名为SeatCatholique.org的在线论坛上以多个用户名发布了数百条帖子，在这些帖子中他质疑上帝和他的信仰。在大约谋杀案发生前一年，他发起了一个名为“牺牲的必要性”的帖子，并与其他用户展开了激烈的辩论。他说：“牺牲的概念，无论是血腥的还是非血腥的，是人类的还是动物的，都与所有宗教密不可分，尤其是我们的宗教。”
is intrinsically linked to all religions, and especially ours. In May that year, he wrote, 99% of the people who killed another human being did it by finding it perfectly normal and justified. Investigators contacted the site's forum moderator, who revealed that Xavier had been banned several times for, quote, "...systematically deflecting all the topics he was involved in." Whenever Xavier was banned, he would create a new account and re-engage the community. In another recovered file, Xavier had written,
与所有宗教都密不可分，尤其是我们的宗教。当年5月，他写道：“99%杀害另一个人的人都认为这是完全正常和合理的。”调查人员联系了该网站的论坛版主，版主透露泽维尔曾多次被封禁，原因是“……系统性地转移他所参与的所有话题的焦点”。每当泽维尔被封禁时，他就会创建一个新账户并重新加入该社区。在另一个恢复的文件中，泽维尔写道：
In another recovered file, Xavier had written, I think I've got a superiority complex. You could call it that, but it's based on a simple observation. I belong to a group of people who are intelligent, determined, balanced and in good moral and physical health. Such people are rare compared to the masses. His wife was also active on online forums and in 2004, Agnes regularly participated in one based around psychology. In one post, she wrote, I already put many messages on this forum, but I changed my nickname for fear that my husband recognises me. I have worries about my relationship because I have a husband who is very old-fashioned in his way of being in the family. The father is the leader,
在另一个恢复的文件中，泽维尔写道：“我想我有一种优越感。你可以这么叫它，但这基于一个简单的观察。我属于一个由聪明、坚定、平衡且身心健康的人组成的群体。与大众相比，这样的人很少。”他的妻子也很活跃于网络论坛，2004年，阿格尼斯经常参加一个以心理学为基础的论坛。她在其中一篇帖子中写道：“我已经在这个论坛上发了许多消息，但我换了昵称，因为害怕我丈夫认出我。我对我的关系感到担忧，因为我有一个在家庭生活方式上非常古板的丈夫。父亲是一家之主，
he gives an order, we execute without seeing to question or understand. He plays his role of head of the family, of a husband who must bring back his crust, but is neither tender nor huggable nor attentive. Add to that big money worries and you will imagine the atmosphere. Several days later she wrote of lacking everything, including tenderness, love, mutual friends, and sex. Quote, He hates being made to understand that his behaviour does not please. He feels attacked and humiliated, belittled. Agnes also confessed to feeling attracted to other men and having virtual affairs.
他下达命令，我们执行，而无需质疑或理解。他扮演着一家之主的角色，扮演着必须带回面包的丈夫的角色，但他既不温柔，也不好抱，更不体贴。再加上巨大的金钱焦虑，你可以想象那种气氛。”几天后，她写道自己缺乏一切，包括温柔、爱、共同的朋友和性。引用：“他讨厌别人让他明白他的行为不受欢迎。他感到被攻击、被羞辱、被贬低。”阿格尼斯还坦白自己被其他男人吸引，并有过精神出轨。
She noted that her husband had once told her, quote, If we all die at once, then everything would be over. In the months leading up to the murders, Xavier had been in contact with several ex-girlfriends, including one from Germany named Claudia. The pair had originally met in Paris in the early 1980s and were close to getting married until Xavier broke things off due to religious differences. As they had stayed in touch over the years, investigators questioned whether she might have information regarding his whereabouts. Claudia became one of their strongest leads. However, efforts to track her down were difficult
她指出，她的丈夫曾对她说，引用：“如果我们一下子都死了，那么一切就都结束了。”在谋杀案发生前的几个月里，泽维尔一直与几个前女友保持着联系，其中包括一个名叫克劳迪娅的德国女子。两人最初于20世纪80年代初在巴黎相遇，原本快要结婚，直到泽维尔因宗教分歧而分道扬镳。由于这些年来他们一直保持联系，调查人员怀疑她是否掌握有关他下落的信息。克劳迪娅成了他们最强有力的线索之一。然而，追踪她的努力十分艰难，
as authorities didn't know her surname. A friend who had accompanied Xavier on a trip to Germany in 1983 said Claudia's apartment was located in the city of Hannover and police aimed to launch a public appeal in February 2013 to identify and locate her, but abandoned the plan last minute amid privacy concerns. concerns. In April 2013, Xavier's brother-in-law, Bertram, tracked down a vital email exchange between Xavier and Claudia that enabled German officials to successfully locate her. Nantes police travelled to Munich to question her, though the result was anticlimactic. She hadn't spoken to Xavier recently and couldn't provide any information to further assist with the search. On April 9 2013, as the two-year anniversary of the murders approached, investigators conducted a large-scale search of mountain ranges located
因为当局不知道她的姓氏。一位曾在1983年陪同泽维尔前往德国的朋友说，克劳迪娅的公寓位于汉诺威市，警方原本打算在2013年2月发出公开呼吁以确认并找到她，但由于隐私顾虑在最后一刻放弃了计划。顾虑。2013年4月，泽维尔的姐夫伯特兰（Bertram）追踪到了一封泽维尔和克劳迪娅之间的关键电子邮件往来，这使得德国官员成功找到了她。南特警察前往慕尼黑讯问她，不过结果有些反高潮。她最近没有和泽维尔交谈过，也无法提供任何有助于进一步搜寻的信息。2013年4月9日，随着谋杀案两周年纪念日的临近，调查人员对位于
61 kilometres southwest of the town where Xavier was last seen. The area featured old, steep and difficult to access lead mines that had been used to conceal the bodies of murder victims in the past. Acting on the possibility that Xavier had taken his life in this remote area, cave divers searched the old mines but found no sign of him. They returned several weeks later on May 2, focusing on a two hectare area of woodland that contained mines, cavities, wells and caves, but once again uncovered nothing of value. Close to two months later, the body of a heavily decomposed man was found hanging from a tree in a wooded area 20 kilometres from Xavier's last known whereabouts.
泽维尔最后被目击的城镇西南61公里的山区进行了大规模搜查。该地区有着古老、陡峭且难以接近的铅矿，过去曾被用来隐藏谋杀案受害者的尸体。出于泽维尔可能在这个偏远地区自杀的猜测，洞穴潜水员搜寻了这些旧矿，但没有发现他的踪迹。几周后的5月2日，他们再次返回，将重点放在了一个占地两公顷的林区，里面有矿井、空洞、水井和洞穴，但再次没有发现任何有价值的东西。近两个月后，在一处距离泽维尔最后已知行踪20公里的林区里，一具高度腐烂的男尸被发现悬挂在树上。
Anticipation that the body was that of Xavier Dupont de Léganès was quickly dismissed by DNA testing. by DNA testing. Despite the overwhelming evidence to suggest otherwise, Xavier's mother, Genevieve, and sister, Christine, refused to believe he was guilty and were convinced of his story about working undercover for the DEA. They believed the murders were part of a conspiracy orchestrated by United States officials to cover up the family's admission into witness protection. They based their theory on the belief that the bodies found under the Dupont de Ligonès home were not those of Agnes, Arthur, Thomas, Anne and Benoit, but decoys. Neither woman was given the opportunity to view the bodies,
尸体是泽维尔·杜蓬·德·莱加内斯的期望很快被DNA检测所否定。被DNA检测所否定。尽管有压倒性的证据表明并非如此，但泽维尔的母亲热纳维耶夫（Genevieve）和妹妹克里斯蒂娜（Christine）拒绝相信他有罪，并坚信他为美国缉毒局（DEA）做卧底的故事。他们认为谋杀案是美国官员精心策划的一场阴谋，旨在掩盖该家庭进入证人保护计划的事实。他们的理论依据是，在杜蓬·德·利戈内斯家底下发现的尸体不是阿格尼斯、亚瑟、托马斯、Anne和伯努瓦的，而是诱饵。这两位女性都没有机会看到尸体，
which they believed had been released for burial suspiciously quickly. However, in cases where heavy decomposition has occurred, DNA testing and dental records are used to save families from the trauma of viewing their loved one's disfigured remains. Genevieve and Christine also noted the heights and weights of the victims were out by a few centimetres on their autopsy reports. Yet, the bodies were buried more than two weeks before they were discovered, meaning some level of shrinkage was to be expected. They pointed out Xavier's behaviour was not akin to someone who had just
她们认为这些尸体被放出来安葬的速度快得可疑。然而，在发生严重腐烂的情况下，通常会使用DNA检测和牙科记录来免除家属看到亲人面目全非的遗体所带来的创伤。热纳维耶夫和克里斯蒂娜还指出，受害者的身高和体重在尸检报告上与实际有几厘米的误差。然而，尸体在被发现前已经埋葬了两周多，这意味着预料到一定程度的收缩是正常的。她们指出，泽维尔的行为不像是一个刚
carried out a violent crime and was on the run from the police. He made no attempt to hide his purchase of garbage bags, lime, cement, bullets, or the silencer for his rifle. Following his escape, Xavier used his credit cards to pay for hotels and allowed himself to be recorded on CCTV, actions his family believed a murderer fleeing authorities would never do. They referred to the arthritis in his shoulder and his recurring back problem to prove he wouldn't have been able to dig the mass grave under the terrace, which required moving two and a half cubic metres of solid earth. In April 2012, one year after the murders, Christine created a blog titled Another Point of View on the Dupont-DeLeganesque Case, in which she shared aspects of the case
犯下暴力罪行并正在逃避警方追捕的人。他没有试图隐瞒他购买垃圾袋、生石灰、水泥、子弹或步枪消音器的行为。逃跑后，泽维尔用信用卡支付酒店费用，并让自己被闭路电视拍到，家属认为一个逃避当局追捕的凶手永远不会这样做。她们提到了他肩膀上的关节炎和反复发作的背部问题，以证明他不可能在露台下挖出需要搬运两点五立方米坚硬泥土的大规模墓穴。2012年4月，即谋杀案发生一年后，克里斯蒂娜创建了一个名为“关于杜蓬-德莱加内斯案的另一个观点”的博客，并在其中分享了她发现案件中
she found questionable, details about Xavier's character and what she regarded as evidence that supported her theory. She acknowledged that her family's findings were shocking, but that they needed to be highlighted to ensure Xavier benefited from the presumption of innocence. In her blog, Christine claimed that Xavier had sent an email to two of his friends less than a year before the murders, saying that if an accident were ever to befall his family, quote, I hope that even after a police investigation, my parents, brothers and sisters will never be led to believe that I intentionally caused
可疑的方面、关于泽维尔性格的细节以及她认为支持其理论的证据。她承认她家人的发现令人震惊，但需要强调这些以确保泽维尔享有无罪推定。在她的博客中，克里斯蒂娜声称泽维尔在谋杀案发生不到一年前曾给他的两个朋友发过一封电子邮件，称如果他的家人遭遇意外，引用：“我希望即使在警方调查之后，我的父母、兄弟姐妹也永远不会被引导去相信我是故意造成
these accidents, even if the evidence is strong. He reportedly asked his friends to store the email in a special folder in case it could help him out in the future. Christine also reported that around the end of March 2011, an anxious and scared Agnes told two friends from her prayer group that someone had been making threats against her and Xavier. Agnes had allegedly changed her email address and phone number, with one friend claiming, quote, it seemed like she wanted to cut the bridges with something or someone. Christine was certain Agnes was complicit in the plan to leave and that the text messages purportedly sent to friends from Thomas and Anne's mobile phones afterwards were written
这些意外的，即使证据确凿。”据报道，他要求朋友将这封电子邮件保存在一个特殊的文件夹中，以防将来能帮到他。克里斯蒂娜还报告说，大约在2011年3月底，一个焦虑和害怕的阿格尼斯曾对她祈祷小组的两个朋友说，有人一直在对他和泽维尔发出威胁。阿格尼斯据称更改了她的电子邮件地址和电话号码，其中一位朋友声称：“看起来她想切断与某物或某人的联系。”克里斯蒂娜确信阿格尼斯是离家计划的同谋，之后据称发给朋友的来自托马斯和安妮手机的短信也是用
in a way that was characteristic of their mother. The blog also alleged that Agnes sent friends an email post departure that simply contained a photo of the Statue of Liberty. Xavier's family retained a lawyer named Stéphane Goldstein to represent their interests. In a 2013 interview with L'Epoir magazine, he said, My position as a lawyer is not easy. This file is out of the ordinary, and even if I do not share the theses alleged by my clients, I cannot dismiss any hypothesis. Because, in this file, errors were made. Huge flaws remain. We do not even know when the victims were killed. In reality, there is no certainty in this case, except that bodies were discovered at 55 Robert Schuman Boulevard. Despite reports stating otherwise, Goldstein claimed that DNA tests had only established a familial relationship
一种具有他们母亲特征的方式编写的。博客还声称，阿格尼斯在离开后给朋友们发了一封电子邮件，里面只包含一张自由女神像的照片。泽维尔的家人聘请了一名名叫斯蒂芬·戈德斯坦（Stéphane Goldstein）的律师来代表他们的利益。在2013年接受《L'Espoir》杂志采访时，他说：“我作为律师的立场并不容易。这份卷宗不同寻常，即使我不分享我的客户所主张的论点，我也不能排除任何假设。因为在这份卷宗中，犯下了错误。巨大的漏洞依然存在。我们甚至不知道受害者是什么时候被杀害的。实际上，在这个案子里没有任何确定的事情，除了在罗伯特·舒曼大道55号发现了尸体。”尽管有相反的报道，戈德斯坦声称DNA测试仅仅确定了受害者之间的血缘关系，
between the victims, but did not confirm they were members of the Dupont-DeLeganes family. He described the autopsy reports as negligent and said there was no way Xavier could have dug the hole under the terrace alone. Quote, There is enough evidence in this file to tip the balance in favour of my client's assumptions. I searched the truth without assuming Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès' guilt. In this case, it was assumed that Xavier had murdered his family before disappearing. No other trail was explored. hearing. No other trail was explored. The case remained open and as the months and years passed with Xavier still missing, armchair
但并未证实他们是杜蓬-德莱加内斯家族的成员。他将尸检报告描述为疏忽大意，并表示泽维尔不可能独自在露台下挖出那个洞。引用：“这份文件中有足够的证据将天平倾向于我客户的假设。我在不假设泽维尔·杜蓬·德·利戈内斯有罪的情况下寻找真相。在这个案件中，人们假定泽维尔在失踪前谋杀了他的家人。没有探索其他线索。”听证会。没有探索其他线索。该案仍然悬而未决，随着时间的推移，泽维尔依然失踪，业余
sleuths gathered online to discuss the ongoing investigation and the prime suspect's possible whereabouts or outcome. Some speculated that Xavier had gone on the run not from law enforcement, but from another unknown threat. Relatives of the Dupont-DeLeganes family joined in on the debates, offering further insight into Xavier's background. Some were willing to believe his sister's theory that the family were still alive. On Wednesday July 15 2015, just over four years after the murders, a Paris-based journalist working for the international news agency Agence France-Presse received an envelope by post. It contained a candid photograph of brothers Arthur and Benoit Dupont de Liguenesse sitting side by side at a dining room table.
侦探们聚集在网上讨论正在进行的调查以及头号嫌疑人的可能下落或结局。一些人推测泽维尔逃跑不是为了躲避执法部门，而是为了躲避另一个未知的威胁。杜蓬-德莱加内斯家族的亲属也加入了辩论，为泽维尔的背景提供了进一步的见解。有些人愿意相信他姐姐的理论，即这家人还活着。2015年7月15日星期三，就在谋杀案发生四年多后，一位为国际新闻机构法新社工作的驻巴黎记者通过邮政收到了一个信封。里面有一张坦率的照片，照片中兄弟亚瑟和伯努瓦·杜蓬·德·利盖内斯并排坐在餐桌旁。
Arthur appeared to be mid-conversation with someone on the other side of the table while Benoit was eating a meal and looking down at his plate. Handwritten in French on the back of the photo were the capitalised words, I am still alive. Underneath in smaller writing it read, From then until this time, not July 11 2015 and was signed with the name Xavier Dupont de Léganès. with the name Xavier Dupont de Léganès. Debate soared over whether the message was genuine or not. The photo had never been published before, yet Arthur and Benoit appeared to be the same age in the image as they were at the time of their murder. Members of Xavier's family dismissed it as a fake, adamant that Xavier would reach out to them
亚瑟似乎正在与桌子另一边的人交谈，而伯努瓦则在吃饭并低头看着盘子。照片背面用法语手写了大写单词：“我还活着。”下方用较小的字写着：“从那时到现在，不是2015年7月11日”，并签署了泽维尔·杜蓬·德·莱加内斯的名字。署名为泽维尔·杜蓬·德·莱加内斯。关于这条消息是否真实，引发了激烈的争论。这张照片以前从未发表过，但亚瑟和伯努瓦在图像中的年龄似乎与他们被谋杀时的年龄一样。泽维尔家人的成员将其斥为伪造，坚信泽维尔会联系他们
long before he contacted the press. Additionally, it seemed almost impossible that he would still be in Nantes. A photojournalist from Nantes thought he recognised the photo and went digging through his archives. He discovered that in 2011, he had seen the image during the silent march held in the wake of the murders and taken a photo of it, which he still had on file, confirming it was not recent. The photo and envelope were tested for DNA and fingerprints while the handwriting was analysed, with police ultimately dismissing it as a hoax. the handwriting was analysed, with police ultimately dismissing it as a hoax. Over the years, alleged sightings of Xavier Dupont de Léganès continued to be reported from far and wide, including one in central France on Monday October 17 2016.
远在联系媒体之前。此外，他似乎几乎不可能还在南特。南特的一位摄影记者认为他认出了这张照片，并在他的档案中进行了搜寻。他发现，在2011年，他在谋杀案发生后举行的静默游行中看到了这个图像，并拍下了一张照片，他仍然将它存档，证实这不是最近的。警方对照片和信封进行了DNA和指纹检测，并对笔迹进行了分析，最终将其斥为一场恶作剧。警方对笔迹进行了分析，最终将其斥为一场恶作剧。多年来，关于泽维尔·杜蓬·德·莱加内斯的目击报告继续从四面八方传来，其中包括2016年10月17日星期一在法国中部的一次目击。
A man bearing a strong resemblance to Xavier caught the attention of bystanders after fleeing a casino without claiming his winnings. After reviewing CCTV footage, investigators deemed the resemblance to be so remarkable that the sighting seemed reliable. A spokesperson told the media, This is a highly sensitive affair and we are doing all we can to verify the likeness. We fully intend to bring this man to justice. A manhunt was launched and the individual was located, who turned out to be no more than a lookalike. be no more than a lookalike. Fourteen months later, police received a tip-off that Xavier was seeking refuge in an isolated monastery in Roquebrune-sur-Argence that served as a place of worship for a reclusive order of Catholic monks. Given its proximity to the location where Xavier was last seen, it had already been searched in 2011, but no sign of the fugitive was
一个酷似泽维尔的男子在逃离一家赌场却未领取奖金后引起了旁观者的注意。在查阅了闭路电视监控画面后，调查人员认为其相似度惊人，以至于这次目击似乎是可靠的。一位发言人告诉媒体：“这是一起高度敏感的事件，我们正在尽一切努力核实相似度。我们完全打算将这个人绳之以法。”一场搜捕行动随即展开，该个人被定位，结果发现不过是一个长相相似的人。不过是一个长相相似的人。十四个月后，警方接到线报称，泽维尔正在罗克布吕讷-叙尔-阿尔让的一个孤立修道院中寻求庇护，该修道院是天主教隐修修士的礼拜场所。鉴于其靠近泽维尔最后一次被目击的地点，该修道院在2011年就已经被搜查过，但没有发现逃犯的任何踪迹。
uncovered. In 2018, two worshippers recognised one of the monks who regularly served mass as bearing a resemblance to Xavier. During morning mass on Tuesday January 9 2018, two plainclothes detectives entered the chapel where four monks, including the one suspected to be Xavier, were giving the holy sacrament to four worshippers. The one purported to be Xavier was identified as 53-year-old brother Jean-Marie Joseph, who was oblivious to the fact he'd been pinned as the wanted mass murderer. Brother Joseph had been living at the monastery for many years, including when the murders took place. He later told a French news network that while he could accept that his age and height corresponded with Xavier's, the two bore no other resemblances. He found it hard to conceive that a monastery could be
被揭露。2018年，两名信众认出经常主持弥撒的一名修士酷似泽维尔。2018年1月9日星期二的晨祷期间，两名便衣侦探进入了小教堂，当时四名修士（包括被怀疑是泽维尔的那位）正在向四名信众发放圣礼。那个被认为可能是泽维尔的人被确认为53岁的让-玛丽·约瑟夫修士，他全然不知自己已被认定为通缉杀人犯。约瑟夫修士已经在该修道院生活了多年，包括谋杀案发生的时候。他后来告诉一家法国新闻网络，虽然他可以接受他的年龄和身高与泽维尔相符，但两人没有其他相似之处。他觉得很难想象一个修道院会
suspected of hiding a mass murderer and said that if Xavier had approached, he would have told him to surrender. The Dupont de Liguenesse house on Robert Schumann Boulevard remained under the seal of the Judicial Police until 2012. In 2014, it was renovated, repainted and put on the market, where it sat for over a year. In January of 2015, it finally sold to a couple for less than half of the original asking price. As of late 2019, the case is still open and will remain so as long as the examining magistrate deems necessary. Over the years, there have been over 900 reported sightings of the suspect, but none have ever been confirmed. 58-year-old
被怀疑藏匿了一名大规模杀人犯，并表示如果泽维尔走近，他会叫他投降。位于罗伯特舒曼大道的杜蓬·德·利戈内斯之宅一直处于司法警察的查封之下，直到2012年。2014年，它经过翻新、重新粉刷并挂牌出售，闲置了一年多。2015年1月，它终于以不到最初要价一半的价格卖给了一对夫妇。截至2019年底，该案仍在调查中，并且只要预审法官认为有必要，就会一直悬而未决。多年来，有超过900起关于嫌疑人的目击报告，但没有一起得到证实。58岁的
Xavier Dupont de Léganès is said to be one of the most wanted men in France However, as Christine highlighted on her blog, her brother does not appear on Interpol's list of wanted persons Christine's blog is no longer active She made her final post on May 13 2013, saying she had shared all the available information and it had served its purpose. She explained those who knew Xavier, Agnes, Arthur, Thomas, Anne and Benoit Dupont de Léganès personally would inevitably always share a different perspective from the public, reiterating her belief that the family's disappearance was not criminal but part of a classified case. The blog refers to a famous
泽维尔·杜蓬·德·莱加内斯被据称是法国最被通缉的人之一。然而，正如克里斯蒂娜在她的博客中所强调的那样，她的兄弟并没有出现在国际刑警组织的通缉犯名单上。克里斯蒂娜的博客不再活跃。她在2013年5月13日发布了她的最后一条消息，称她已经分享了所有可用的信息，并且它已经达到了目的。她解释说，那些亲自认识泽维尔、阿格尼斯、亚瑟、托马斯、安妮和伯努瓦·杜蓬·德·莱加内斯的人不可避免地总是会与公众分享不同的视角，并重申了她坚信这起家庭失踪案不是犯罪而是机密案件的一部分。该博客引用了一句著名的
quote from Mahatma Gandhi which says, An error does not become truth by reason of multiplied propagation, nor does truth become error because nobody sees it. The theory that Xavier took his own life following the murders remains prevalent. Some argue this would have gone against his religious beliefs as suicide is considered a mortal sin in Catholicism. But according to the book The Dupont de Léganès Case by journalist Guy Oignet, Xavier had become disillusioned with his faith and had debated with family members in the past about the moral issues surrounding suicide. It didn't pose a problem to Xavier, who argued that
圣雄甘地的话：“一个错误不会因为多次传播而变成真理，真理也不会因为没有人看到它而变成错误。”泽维尔在谋杀后自杀的理论仍然很普遍。有些人认为这会违背他的宗教信仰，因为自杀在天主教中被认为是大罪。但根据记者盖伊·瓦伊涅（Guy Oignet）的书《杜蓬·德·莱加内斯案》，泽维尔已经对他的信仰感到幻灭，并在过去与家人讨论过围绕自杀的道德问题。这对泽维尔来说并不成问题，他辩称
everyone has the right to end their own life. Some believe he had been planning the murder-suicide for several months to escape his mounting financial problems and had gone to great lengths to cover it up because he didn't want to be identified as someone who would kill his own family. In 2016, Jean-René Persinic, the former head of Nantes Judicial Police, said, We work on facts, not impressions. Without proof of death, the only method that is worth considering is living. If Xavier's corpse is discovered, authorities have confirmed he will be presumed guilty and the case will be closed. On Friday October 11 2019, as the case file team was preparing this episode, the following news made headlines across the world.
每个人都有结束自己生命的权利。有人认为，为了摆脱日益沉重的经济压力，他可能几个月前就开始策划这起谋杀后自杀的案件，并且费尽心机掩盖真相，因为他不想被贴上杀死自己家人的标签。2016年，南特司法警察局前局长让-雷涅·佩西尼克表示：“我们依据事实办事，而不是凭印象。在没有死亡证明的情况下，唯一值得考虑的假设就是他还活着。”当局已经证实，如果发现泽维尔的尸体，他将被推定有罪，案件也将随之结案。2019年10月11日星期五，正当案卷团队在筹备本期节目时，以下新闻登上了全球各大媒体的头条：
Airport staff at the Charles de Gaulle airport in Paris contacted authorities after a man boarded a flight to Scotland using a stolen French passport. The passenger was arrested without incident upon his arrival to the city of Glasgow. Hours later, news reports announced that fingerprint analysis had confirmed the man to be Xavier Dupont de Liguenesse, who had undergone drastic plastic surgery to change his facial features. News of the arrest quickly made worldwide headlines, but in the early hours of Sunday October 13, it was announced that UK authorities had made a mistake. The man was actually 69-year-old Portuguese national Guy Joël, who bore no physical resemblance to Xavier and was not connected to the case in any way. Guy was released after spending a night in custody, with reports stating he and his family
巴黎夏尔·戴高乐机场的工作人员接到当局通报，此前有一名男子使用一本被盗的法国护照登上了飞往苏格兰的航班。这名乘客抵达格拉斯哥市后，被顺利逮捕。几个小时后，新闻报道宣布，指纹分析证实该男子正是泽维尔·杜邦·德·利戈内斯，他曾接受过彻底的整容手术以改变面部特征。这一逮捕消息迅速传遍全球，然而在10月13日星期日的凌晨，英国当局宣布他们搞错了。这名男子实际上是一名69岁的葡萄牙籍男子吉·若埃尔，他与泽维尔没有任何外貌上的相似之处，也与本案没有任何关系。吉在被拘留一夜后获释，报道称他和他的家人
were very distressed by the incident. French officials have placed the blame for the error on Scottish police, who claim they were simply acting under instructions from the French authorities. The true whereabouts of Xavier Dupont de Léganès remain unknown. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对这起事件感到非常痛苦。法国官员将这一失误归咎于苏格兰警方，而苏格兰警方则声称他们只是奉法国当局的指示行事。泽维尔·杜邦·德·利戈内斯的真实下落仍然是个谜。谢谢收听。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。